This lesson is about
Task Queue.
If you thought Memcache is cool,
being able to take whole
layers of caching that you could
share between all those
instances, Task Queue
is so much cooler.
It's just amazing what you can
do with it and how much you
could enhance your application
and make it more
scalable and reliable.
What is Task Queue, and why
do I love it so much?
The different kinds of task
queues that we have, the push
and the pull queue, as well as
cron jobs, or scheduled tasks.
A task is just a unit of work.
For example, let me write an
object to the datastore or
send an email, something that
could be a compartmentalized
unit of function, or something
that you'd want to run out of
the user context.
For example, if the user runs a
web page, and that web page
does something and then uses
an email, it doesn't make
sense for that user to sit there
waiting for that email
to be sent.
Task Queue is a great way to
take that piece of work and
put it on a different queue
while it automatically
processes in the background,
while the user's request
continues processing.
All versions of your
applications
share the same queue.
A push queue is really for
automatic execution.
You push something on a queue,
and it will immediately
execute it.
Pull Queue is slightly
different, where you can
actually put a piece of work
on this queue, and then you
can take a lease from it by a
worker thread that you can
control, like how fast you pick
up those queues, as well
as where you pick them up from,
whether it's Compute
Engine or on-premise system.
There's a few basics
about all tasks.
Each one has a name when you
put it on the task queue.
If you don't specify
one, it will
automatically generate one.
If you try to put a task on the
queue with the same name,
it will actually fail.
I have here the top
and the bottom.
The task on the top is the type
of parameters that you
can control for a push queue.
And the bottom is the type of
data and parameters that you
can have for a pull queue.
Notice there's a lot
more information
about a push queue.
The reason why is that
a push queue--
a good way of thinking about
it is it's just a URL along
with some parameter options that
are going to be executed
on one of your front-end
instances.
And it's going to try to do this
as quickly as possible.
You could put some quality and
control around the queue.
And the way you do that
is different for the
two types of queues.
The push queue, you put these
pieces of work on the queue,
and it will get executed
as quickly as possible.
It may cause a lot of instances
to be spun up, so
you have to be careful about
how many you put on, or at
least how quickly that queue
is going to drain and send
tasks to your application.
One nice feature is on
frontends, you normally have a
60-second deadline where
the request has to
be completed by.
If that request is initiated by
a task queue, then you have
a full 10 minutes to finish
that request.
If you do it on the backend,
of course, you have an
unlimited amount of time
to finish that request.
But when you are creating a push
queue, you are limited to
100 kilobytes of total data
with that request.
Since this is just a standard
request that comes from a user
to your application, you can
have either a Get request or a
Post request.
And you can have a whole payload
that is that post
body, just like someone is
posting a form to your
application.
A pull queue, however, you
have an instance that you
would spin up.
And you would then go to
that queue and get a
lease on some tasks.
You could crunch through
your work.
And then when you're done with
that work, you'd go and see
that you would delete that task,
essentially saying that
you've completed the processing
for that task.
We have a complete REST
interface over the pull queue.
This allows you, then, to run
your worker from anywhere.
It could be on-premise, it could
be another App Engine
instance, either frontends
or backends.
You have a maximum of 1
megabyte in task size.
Unlike a push task, where you
have parameters that get
posted or get appended as the
request, this is actually a
piece of data that when you
release the task, you
get that data back.
Every queue you have in your
system you can actually name
and put in parameters
about that queue--
for example, how frequently or
fast you're going to process
these tasks, or how large
a token bucket is.
The basic concept is we use a
token-bucket algorithm in
order to limit how frequently
or how quickly we drain or
process your tasks.
You can have a bunch of queues
that you can create and you
could specify different
parameters.
But you also have a default
queue that's
already set for you.
And its name is just Default.
Also by default, there is an
unlimited concurrent request.
If you have a lot of requests on
this task queue, it's going
to start saving them
and trying to
process as many as possible.
Unless you control it, it will
start to spin a lot of
frontend instances.
For example, in the illustration
here is that you
have one queue that
says, one request
currently, and may be faster.
Think of it as a bigger pipe.
Whereas maybe another queue
that says, I only want to
process one concurrently.
And that's a smaller pipe that
kind of funnels the traffic
into one at a time and would
prevent more and more
instances from being spun up.
Unless you specify otherwise,
every single task that you put
on the queue is going to be
executed by the same version
that initiated that task.
So if you're the default
application, it's going to go
on that queue.
And it's going to try to
execute that URL on the
default version of
that application.
If you're in, say, version 3 of
your application, and you
execute a task in that version,
it's going to go back
to version 3.
You can override this
behavior as well.
What's nice about this is if
you deploy a new version of
that application and put
something on the task, and
even though the task are shared,
it's going to go back
to the same version
that you deployed.
So you could test new
functionality out, and you
don't have to worry about it
calling between different
applications.
So what does this mean?
Well, let's say that you have a
processing rate of 1 second.
You have bucket size of 5.
So you get 7 new tasks.
Well, you're going to
execute the first
five tasks right away.
But it's going to have to wait
for a second later to get
another token to execute the
sixth task, and then again for
the seventh task.
Another way of showing this
is on a time line.
Every time we execute a task,
we use one of these tokens.
But now we wait for that token
to come back and fill up the
bucket again.
If we increase that rate to 2
seconds, then, of course, you
still can consume the same
five tokens right away.
But you get a new token halfway
through that because
it's every half second.
You get a new token when you
execute the seventh task,
sixth and seventh tasks.
So this is how you could really
control how frequently
and how quickly you
execute the tasks.
And here you get more
and more tokens.
And the way you would configure
it is these have
different parameters--
the task-retry-limit, which is
the minimum number of times to
retry the task before
it fails.
And some of these are used in
conjunction with one another.
So you can also have
task-retry-time, which is the
minimum amount of time
to retry a task.
So in this example,
the minimum- and
maximum-backup-seconds have to
do with how long you wait
between subsequent retries.
The max-doubling is how much
of an exponential backoff
you're getting.
So to put all these things
together, if we have that
retry limit of 1, the retry
limit of 4 seconds, which is
really the minimum number of
times we're going to try to
attempt it, and the
minimum/max-backoff of 1
second to 4 seconds, we'll see
that the first time we fail a
task, it retries it
a second later.
But we've already now
gone over that 1
minimum-retry-limit.
But we're going to keep trying
because we haven't yet hit the
minimum time we want to
continue a retry.
So then if it fails a second
time, we retry it again.
And we still yet haven't
hit that for a second.
So we're going to
try it again.
And each time, we're getting a
little bit longer because of
that doubling.
But since we've satisfied, at
this point, both the retry
limit of 1 and the retry limit
of 4 seconds, we're then going
to fail that task and not
continue to retry it.
So let's say that we increase
the retry limit to the number
5, but we keep the same minimum
and max backoff seconds.
You notice that the minimum
backoff is 1 second.
And so the first time
it retries is
going to be 1 second.
And I'm using seconds
for illustrations.
Usually it isn't terribly
accurate, because it could
take longer to execute
the tasks.
You're usually dealing with
minutes or hours for these
types of retries.
Now we double it, though, to
2 seconds and to 3 seconds.
Essentially, we keep multiplying
by the number of
seconds that we identify as the
minimum backoff seconds.
And the max-doubling is
what controls the
increment of each time.
Since I have 0, that means
it's not going to double.
It's going to increase
my minimum by
that amount each time.
My minimum is 1 second, so
it would be 1 second.
If I had a max-doubling, it
would go from 1 to 2 to 4, et
cetera, until you have the
maximum number of times it
would be doubled.
0 just simply means, keep
incrementing by that 1 second.
So you'll see that we've
hit 4 seconds here.
But our max backoff
is 4 seconds--
meaning, don't keep extending
it beyond 4 seconds.
So now every subsequent request
is going to retry
every 4 seconds until we've
satisfied both the minimum
number of times we want to retry
as well as the amount of
time we want to keep
retrying for.
Since we've tried five times,
we're greater than 4 seconds.
And that would be over here.
We would then stop after
that last request.
Here's a simple code to put
a task on the queue.
It's so easy just to
say, here's my URL
and here's my parameter.
Then this is going to
automatically submit a post
request to the parameter of
"id's equal 1, 2, and 3." It's
literally that easy.
Then you would, of course,
program whatever handler you
would want to do to handle that
forward-slash worker request.
In Python, it's very
similar format.
One of the most challenging
concepts is, how do we limit
the rate of tasks that
are being executed?
And really, what's happening
underneath the hood?
We use a token-bucket
algorithm.
And think of it, literally, as
a bucket that has tokens.
If we have a refill rate of 1
second-- which means we want
to process it at
once a second--
then every second, we take a new
token and we put it right
in this bucket.
If the bucket's already full
with our max bucket size, then
we just disregard that token.
So you can always have
a bucket that's
constantly being refilled.
Whenever we executed a new task,
it's going to take one
of those tokens out of the
bucket and execute the task.
So that means we're
going to start
taking a bunch of tokens.
But once that bucket is empty,
we can't process that request
until a new token gets
added to the bucket.
Within one second, that token
would be replenished.
Another way of showing this
is on a time line.
Every time we execute a task,
we use one of those tokens.
But now empty, and we wait for
that token to come back and
fill up the bucket again.
If we increase that rate to 2
seconds, then, of course, you
can still consume the same
tokens right away.
But you get a new token halfway
through that, because
it's every half a second.
You get a new token when you
execute the seventh task,
sixth and seventh tasks.
So this is how you could really
control how frequently
and how quickly you
execute the tasks.
And here you get more
and more tokens.
So let's say you want
to delete a task.
There's a couple of
ways to do that.
One is you could go through your
admin interface in the
console and just purge the whole
task or, actually, check
on individual tasks
and delete them.
Or you could do that
programmatically through code.
In Java you would just
load the queue.
Then you would delete the task
by specifying the task name.
So if you had told it or didn't
give it a task name
when you created the task,
you would know
which task to delete.
So you would have to correlate
it, figure it out, then do
that deletion.
If you had specified the same
task, then, of course, you
could just use that
name very easily.
You could also just purge the
entire queue, which would
delete all tasks.
Another nice feature, though, in
the task queue is that you
can schedule tasks based on the
part of the transaction.
We're talking about
the datastore.
So let's say you wanted to add
something to the datastore,
and then you wanted to trigger
off a process that would go
through and update an average
for some reason.
Perhaps you have a +1 button.
And every time someone pluses
it, you want to get the
average of or count of, for
example, you would increment
that count in a separate task.
But you only want to actually
schedule that task if that
datastore transaction
was successful.
And so this is how you would
do it as part of a
transaction.
When tasks are actually calling
your application,
there are a few different
headers that are
automatically added.
Something that's nice about
these headers is that the App
Engine system automatically
strips everything that begins
with anything that we add
ourselves, will strip it if
someone tries to spoof that
send-a-request to your
application.
And so if these headers exist,
you could rely that they're
actually added by our own
infrastructure and not by
someone trying to trick you.
Your name, task queue-- pretty
self explanatory.
We try to count the number of
times it's been retried.
Execution count is the number
of times it's been executed.
And TaskETA, which is roughly
how long until it's going to
be executed.
Another nice feature of Task is
that if you want it to be
right away, you can specify
how long until you
want it to be run.
That is, I want it to be run
in 1,000 seconds, or at a
particular date and time.
Then there's also a header that
you can set when you're
creating a new task.
And this is a situation--
let's say that you are using
Task to call the backend.
But backend could be dynamic,
or it could be something you
control yourself.
But you don't want to spin up
a new backend instance if
one's not already running.
So let's say you have a bunch
of batch processing that you
want to do in a particular time,
and you don't want to
spend the 15 minutes of
automatically spinning up the
backend and then spinning
it down.
Well, this is a great
way to do it.
If the backend's not up, the
task would wait in that queue
until that backend is brought
online, and then it will
process the tasks.
So pull queue is you
don't really have a
URL that you call.
You just simply have a piece
of work that needs to be
released by a worker.
And this is great for processing
something off site
or a batch operation or
something that doesn't really
need to have that frontend
request that's initiated.
But rather, you want to pull a
bunch of tasks and do a bunch
of work in one thread.
The way this simply works
is that you put the
task on that queue.
And then all work will come and
say, I want to lease one
of the tasks.
It gets that lease, and no other
worker can get a lease
on that task for as long as
your lease is good for.
You can specify a time, pretty
much like a timeout or an
expiration for that lease.
If you don't respond before
that timeout happens, then
some other worker could pick
up that task and start
processing it.
Once you're done processing
it, your worker has to
actually go back and delete the
task so that it's done,
and no other worker
will pick it up.
Here's how you would
code a pull queue.
Java versus Python code
is very similar.
You just get the new queue, and
you give it the name of
that queue.
And you put a new
task onto it.
And set the lease here for an
hour, or 3,600 seconds.
And I want to pull 100 tasks.
That's going to give you an
array list of tasks that you
can then crunch through.
So if you only get one task,
you would specify 1.
This pull queue has the REST
interface that's currently
under "experimental."
But I know a lot of
people that use it.
Keep that in mind, though.
If you run into an issue and
contact Support, they'll say
it's experimental.
They'll try to help you.
You can specify an ACL--
who can actually pull tasks
from this lease?
That's if you're going
to use something
outside of App Engine.
If you want other workers
running on Rackspace or
on-premise, for example.
This is used for on-premise
processing when you do batches
that you might pull data from
a financial or some other
system that's on-premise
they don't want a
direct connection to.
You can have a branch process
running on-premise.
Then you can upload the
data to your app.
You could try this out on the
Google API Playground or the
OAuth Playground to see
how it all works.
So some of the best practices
is like an end-user request.
This end-user request doesn't
actually have a user
associated with it.
So if you use the user API to
call up who's calling it, it
will say no one's logged in.
However, this is treated
as an admin request.
So if you had protected your
application so that the URL
that was being called by the
task queue is protected so it
could be called by an admin
user, then it can also be
called by a task queue.
That's the way to make sure
that something on the
internet's not just trying to
hit the URL and trigger
whatever the task
could trigger.
Yet as an admin when logged in,
you'll be able to trigger
it yourself because it will
treat you as admin as well.
So the best practice is to set
the security to only allow end
points to be accessed by an
admin role unless, of course,
you don't care, and maybe you
want to open publicly.
Use different queues for
different purposes.
So let's say that you have
a lot of very fast
requests that come in.
Well, it's much better to use
different queues so that you
could specify parameters on
those queues to do different
processing rates.
You don't want to have
1,000 reports spin
up at the same time.
Each one could take five
minutes to process.
That's going to spin up a lot
of frontend instances if
you're doing it that way.
Whereas you'd want that
throughput for something
that's small, quick,
and fast request.
You could actually, just like
a lot of our APIs, match up
task creation.
The only limitation is that
you can't do more than 100
tasks per batch.
This is great because you're
going to have a lot less usage
than your API quota for the
task queue, as well as it
could be much faster.
So it will cost less, and
it will perform faster.
Finally, there's a few best
practices for pull queues.
Since we're not going to
automatically trigger this
task for your instances, you
have to determine how quickly
you want to spin workers
up to pull leases.
It's something you have
to control yourself.
You should make sure you choose
a lease time that is
close to the worst-case
scenario.
Otherwise you run into a
situation where something's
still being worked on, and the
lease expires, and a different
worker pulls that task
and starts executing
that request as well.
So the next topic is Cron.
I like to call them
scheduled tasks.
It's really just a task on the
task queue that are scheduled
to run at certain intervals.
It hits that URL, and the
application runs as an admin,
and you could go on.
And for all intents and
purposes, you could treat it
just like any other task queue
that's being executed.
If you've got an admin console,
then you have a queue
that's there named underscore,
underscore, "cron." And you
can actually go on in
the admin console
and pause that queue.
And it will stop processing
all your cron jobs.
You could also tweak a
lot of the different
details about the queue.
You can't control the parameters
like how frequently
it executes them, but
you can purge them.
But you can also
pause a queue.
So if something starts going
crazy, you could just pause
and wait for it to finish.
When it's working OK, you could
resume it all and just
take off where it left off.
So for cron jobs, you would
specify those in cron.xml or
in cron.yaml.
And the important thing is you
have to have at least the URL.
And that's the URL that's
being called,
as well as the schedule.
The schedule is actually in
pretty plain English.
Like every 24 hours means once
every 24 hours to execute.
You could also specify if you
want the target version of
your application to call.
Now, there's a few parameters
that you have
in these cron jobs.
One is the URL on
the schedule.
But you could also specify
the time zone.
So you want to say at, 5:00 PM
in a particular time zone,
call the task.
Now, there's also a special
parameter here called
Synchronized.
And what that means is if it
synchronized, every single
minute, call it regardless of
how long the task took to run.
Whereas if you don't say
"synchronized"--
let's say the task takes two
minutes to run, and you want
to run it every two minutes.
So it runs for the two minutes,
and then it waits
another two minutes, and then
it runs it, effectively
kicking off the cron job every
four minutes because it took
that two minutes to execute.
So now when a cron job is being
executed, the admin
header says "X-AppEngine-Cron
is true." And that's how you
can tell that it has actually
come from Cron
versus the task queue.
Just like the task queue, you'd
want to secure this
using admin.
But if you actually don't
specify "admin," and you
specify "just have to
be logged in as a
user," it will fail.
Because remember, there's no
user associated with either
Task Queue or with
the cron job.
But it comes in as an admin, or
it passes the admin flag.
Now that you have 20 different
cron jobs in three
applications, if you need,
you could have up to 100.